wow 100 miles this looks like impossible  but not not I think 100 mice is even  more possible than a marathon because in  Marathon you have the perspective of  performance and of time and maybe in New  York Marathon it's a bit different  because it's okay I just want to do New  York Marathon no matter the time but  normally people and one running  marathons they want to put time on 100  miles no matter what time you just want  to finish it for the first one out to  the last Runner it's the same goal it's  just to achieve this adventure and this  journey and it's so hard and so  interesting to do but it's not  impossible because it's it could be just  working just running and if if you go it  slowly I'm sure it's possible but you  have to be really passionated about that  and you have to know why you do that  because of course it will be hard but if  you know why you are here if it's a  dream  I'm sure it's possible to do it